[Music]
from John Hughes the Mind behind all
your favorite bathroom scenes
sorry it's real fun isn't it comes a
fantasy about what a teenage boy would
do with a day of complete Freedom
besides the obvious I'm not doing this
for me I'm doing it for you
Ferris Bueller's Day Off made Ferris
Bueller uh-oh
he's white Chicago's favorite sociopath
who could break the fourth wall before
it was pool it's over
go home he'll use his charms to
manipulate the people closest to him you
think I don't care I know you don't care
until all his lies in deceived come
crashing down on his best friend thanks
anyway
[Music]
he'll be fine
join Ferris on a physically impossible
tour of the city from the stock exchange
to the art museum to a baseball game to
a stuffy French restaurant what is he 90
maybe that fan theory is right and he's
just a figment of squigger's imagination
cars don't drive without a third wheel
so along for the ride is Cameron hi
Cameron comfortable
hi Sloan no this eona hockey jersey is a
product of his father's abuse which is
why he takes it from his best friend too
dark I didn't hit you I lightly slapped
you and attempts to hide the drug
addiction that has him spacing out for
half the movie
camera can you hear me why don't you
come in here it's really nice
[Music]
plus there's ferris's girlfriend Sloan
she loves Ferris and she's a girl he's
gonna marry me and description what are
you interested in nothing
me neither hot on their tail is paris's
sister Jeannie who's sick with a case of
player hateritis the only disease that's
ever been cured by kissing Charlie Sheen
ferris's dad who's either deaf hi or
secretly just wants his son to have a
fun senior year and then there's
principal Rooney in an iconic
performance about being so obsessed with
a minor you risk your career in a rare
example of Life imitating art imitating
life ew he's determined to humiliate
Ferris by catching him in the act of
having fun in the city with his
girlfriend in this strange obsession
with one ditcher while the rest of his
school descends into Anarchy the sportos
motorheads Geeks Bloods waist oils
Woods like the gang sir you have much
bigger fish to fry so say oh yeah as you
take a Nostalgia trip back to the John
Hughes verse that returns us to our warm
and fuzzy childhoods
even though everyone was angry and mean
hey
you know you've got the money we just
have to spend it
kid why don't you put your thumb up your
butt
casually racist you speak English
[Music]
and assaulting someone's dog was funny
sleep tight
as long as you eventually got your own
violent painful comeuppance
wait Fair stitches dog that day too okay
screw him I hope Cameron's dad beats him
with a tire iron too dark
starring assemble plan Ferris wheels
friend with benefits on Sloan from the
80s babe collection Baby's Day Out the
bad guy from Howard the Duck and also
real life Chad GED two and a half ounces
anyone anyone anyone it's Ben Stein
special delivery a person should not
believe in it isn't he should believe in
himself nihilism and when someone asks
what's your third favorite Ska band is
say ferris
what
Chicago white spots
casuals like the fan theory that Ferris
is just in Cameron's head real fans
wonder if Ferris is trapped in a Time
Loop or if he had sex with Cameron's mom
is your mother in the room I'm not
worried about your mother or what's up
with a name distribution in his homeroom
Adams Adam Lee adamowski Adamson Adler
Anderson Bueller
Bueller Frye six A's one B then straight
to F where the C's D's and E's been
Stein where do they go help control the
pet population have your pets spayed or
neutered He's Got The Whole World in His
Hands I have another surgery coming up
not because I need it but because I like
the hospital food kiss kiss love you bye